eigentlich wenn wir über das jahr 2020
und das impfen gesprochen haben dann war
da immer der wert von rund 400.000
impfdosen jetzt ist er plötzlich erhöht
worden auf über eine million ist das ein
rechentrick oder ist das was steckt
dahinter
es ist wenn man sich das genau anguckt
also es sollten laut spahn ministerium
dort gesundheitsministerium noch amt
noch gestern morgen gestern mittag bis
zum jahresende nicht mehr als 400.000
impfdosen zur verfügung stehen wir haben
dann bei pfizer dir produzieren für
bayern tag nachgefragt und die sagten ja
die 400.000 stimmen aber die reichen
sogar noch bis in den januar ein also
bis in die erste januarwoche rhein nicht
mehr als 4000 dosen das sind
kleckerbeträge zum beispiel der
landkreis ebersberg in bayern hätte dann
40 dosen abgekriegt also da es in fünf
minuten durch das hat sich abgezeichnet
auch für herrn sparen dass er einige
widerstand und setzten kam aus den
bundesländern als sie gemerkt haben was
dafür dass es somit das ist lecker
sachen sind die da an kommen also dass
die dass die impfung wirklich
tröpfchenweise anfängt das ist viel zu
wenig sein wird und dann hat er gestern
abend plötzlich dann auf twitter
verkündet 1,3 millionen impfdosen also
mehr als das dreifache bis zum
jahresende
wenn man dann allerdings liefern die
zahlen guckt und nochmal nachfragt bei
herta entspannen dann wird deutlich dass
ich überhaupt nicht viel verändert hat
bis ende januar galt bisher immer nicht
mehr als vier millionen impfdosen
dabei bleibt es sind also nur einzelne
lieferungen hat bei und tag auf bitten
des ministeriums vorgezogen wir haben
nicht mehr impfstoff wir haben nur
früher etwas mehr und dafür spielt er
dann wieder etwas weniger impfstoff wie
dramatisch der mangel ist den wir haben
zeigt auch dass selbst der
gesundheitsminister gestern bei den
landesgesundheitsministerin darum
gebeten hat dass nur die hälfte davon
verimpft wird und die andere hälfte
zurück gestellt wird falls nämlich dann
zu dem zeitpunkt wo die leute ihre
zweite impfung kriegen müssen nicht
genügend impfstoff da ist also auch dort
wird offensichtlich mit einer impflücken
gerechnet deswegen wird von diesen 13 45
millionen impfdosen dies genau sein
sollen auch nur die hälfte erst einmal
verimpft die andere hälfte dann drei
wochen später und das ist dann nicht
mehr im dezember sondern im januar und
damit auch die alte rechnung wieder hin
also das war ein taschenspielertrick mit
zahlen von gesundheitsminister
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren